Hello everyone, welcome to another week of HoloTalk.
This is Holo Talk for the week of No, it's not March anymore, it's April.
April 5th, even though we're going up on the 7th.
The reason why we're coming up on the 7th is because we had Dr.
Jaeong.
He was away on vacation.
We didn't get him up to Tuesday of last week, so we wanted to leave him up until Monday night of this week to give him a fair shake.
So uh we're putting this show up on Tuesday.
But if you listened to last week's show, you already know that, and that's why you're tuned in today to hear the new show.
Uh announcements, Lasers and Holograms, which is a traveling exhibit of the Pacific Science Center, is going to be coming to the Discovery Center of Science and Technology of Lehigh University.
It's going to be here through the summer, and that's in Bethlehem, Pennsylvania, which is just next to Allentown, which is just northwest of Philadelphia.
And it's a traveling exhibit with uh laser holography touring exhibit, a lot of interactive things for parents and children to do, and a uh pretty nice exhibit of holograms, uh some very large format holograms of uh uh coupled by uh uh Dr.
John Perry, who's going to be a guest on May 10th on this show.
So if you get a chance, if you live in the uh New York Philly, Baltimore, Washington, D.C.
Carter, it's a quick drive for you.
In fact, it's a non-stop drive for you from anywhere in Baltimore, Washington, Philly, or uh New York City.
You can come in nonstop.
The first red light that you will get that you'll have to stop is just two blocks from the Discovery Center, so it's a quick drive.
Our guests, I'd like to go down the uh list of guests that we have.
Every so often I'll go down the entire list.
Uh this list is going to take us uh right into fall of ninety-eight.
So coming up on April 12th, we have Steve Province of Blue Ridge Holographics, and I just sent Steve an email tonight uh letting him know that he's on for this week.
So as soon as I hear back from him, uh we'll do the interview and get that up uh as soon as possible.
And hopefully we'll have it up for you uh Sunday night as planned with our regular broadcast.
April twenty sixth is L.
Michael Roberts, and he's with Laser FX International.
That's an organization that does all the laser light shows around the world.
So he's going to give us a perspective on how laser light shows are put together.
And you might want to tune in in case you were thinking of actually doing a few laser light shows of your own.
I hear that's uh taking off.
It's getting pretty big where people are getting some laser light show equipment going around and doing nightclubs and school dances and some of the other things that are going on.
So you'll want to tune in for L.
Michael Roberts.
Dr.
John Perry from Holographics North, and they manufacture very large format uh white light transmission holograms up there, the kind that you see at the uh conventions and at the large museums, and like I mentioned a little earlier.
One of uh Dr.
Perry's holograms is included in the laser and hologram exhibit that's uh going to be coming to the Discovery Center.
May twenty-fourth, Jason Sapan of uh holographic studios in New York City.
This is a uh studio that also is probably one of the nice and uh nicest galleries in that we have uh in the northeast uh part of the uh country.
Uh you can go in and actually uh tour the gallery itself.
Uh see a lot of holograms on displays, and he's going to probably fill us in on uh a couple of the production runs that he's doing at his studios as well because he has uh all of his holographic tables and laboratories right there at the location as well.
June seventh is Peter Shire from AD 2000, which is a marketing uh company for holography.
And I think with an email that he had sent me earlier that he wants to discuss uh holography with short runs.
These are uh people who want to have holograms done but they don't necessarily need ten million of them for m for a magazine cover.
So I think he's going to cover uh at least focus on uh short run holography.
Stephen Quest is uh from Quest Laser Light Shows and once again that's going to be on June twenty first and he uh another laser light show uh show that we're going to have here on HoloTalk so if you're interested in laser light shows tune in for Stephen Quest.
July twelfth, George Caligaras and I think I'm pronouncing that name right.
I'm not quite sure and uh George is a uh teacher he's been teaching holography for many many years.
He has a website up for amateur holography and holography and education which is a very popular site and uh he's going to be covering just that on Jodina the week of July twelfth, uh holography and education and probably more or less for the amateur and hobbyist holographer.
July twenty sixth is Arlene Jurich and she also is involved with um holography and education.
She's been teaching holography for many many years.
I've known Or Arlene going way back and um she teaches uh some very unique things using holograms as models uh for the brain and how the brain functions uh and especially in and learning age of children.
So that's gonna be an interesting show that you want to tune in for August 2nd, Sharon McCormick.
And uh Sharon has done some very famous holograms that you may have seen around like uh Sports Illustrated cover that has um Michael Jordan and also uh she did I believe a C D cover for Prince among other things.
And in any case we'll also have a link to her holography site where you can go on and see all the work that uh she's done.
August sixteenth, which is getting close to closing out the seven uh summer we have Steve and Michael and Steven has a wonderful holography site for amateur holography and we're going to have him on talking about amateur and hobbyist holography and talk about his website and the different things and projects he's been working on uh in amateur and hobbyist holography.
So that's our lineup running f from April twelfth which is coming up this week to August sixteenth of this year, which is going to take us into fall and that's all I have on the sheet 'cause there's still probably another show or two in August, but that's all on the sheet and I don't see another sheet with it.
Anyway, that should be enough for everybody.
Okay, let's move on.
We'll do some questions this week.
We had a shortage of questions for a while.
It was a dry spell.
Didn't get any calls or any emails.
It was depressing.
And then all of a sudden got like four or five of them here just uh from in the last uh week.
You've got me okay this question's coming from Michael and Michael asked could you please tell me if anybody has used a hologram of the magazine advertisement would this be very expensive plus could you have a hologram of a cat and then if you hold it one way you see a dog.
Uh yeah I can tell you about the magazine covers there's quite a few uh well you said magazine advertisements but there's been uh mostly on covers I would say um just to grab people's attention um to justify the cost of uh making a hologram and and the production run of putting one on um a printed piece it's uh a lot better to put it on the cover because uh you get the opportunity to grab someone's attention when that magazine's on the stand.
I've seen them used uh I think Car and Driver had a uh Ford Taurus on it, uh Sports Illustrated had Michael Jordan.
Uh let's see what else can I think of course we had the National Geographic covers and as far as advertisements I've uh seen them in in quite a few advertisements.
We've got the Absolute vodka which was a full page ad uh that was just a hologram.
Excuse me, the uh uh McDonald's uh restaurant chain uh took the back cover of one of the uh National Geographic uh covers in fact the entire cover was nothing but a hologram so it's it's used.
Is it very expensive?
Um I get the impression from a lot of people that are involved with the printing industry that it is very expensive uh to them when you compare that to other traditional uh uh premium type of printing that you can do to grab people's attention.
Uh they do consider it expensive the actual prices I don't have at this point.
I imagine um back when the National Geographic covers ran and um you know a lot of these things were quite a few years ago it was uh didn't have as much competition in the marketplace and uh the price was high but I bet you if you went shopping around you could probably find something that was in the price range that you were looking for.
Go to the link page at the uh web zeme uh and there's uh whole page of links and I'm sure there's at least uh half dozen companies on there that's that you could go to their website and find out uh exactly what they do for holographic printing.
Uh if you have a hologram of a cat, and then if you hold it one way, you see a dog.
Yeah, they're called multiple channel holograms.
Uh oh some holograms have a hundred and sixty, 200, three hundred individual exposures uh when you get into the stereograms.
But a lot of holograms uh are multiple channel holograms.
People find them fascinating when they're in the store, and they can look at it one side and see one thing, look at it another way to see another thing.
A couple of them that come to mind are the Star Trek holograms.
Uh I think one's a Borg.
I'm not familiar too familiar with the Star Trek characters, but I think one's a Borg and it changes into different things as you move.
And there's uh another one which is a computer mouse, where you see uh a little real mouse on top of a computer mouse that you use with your hand, and as you move past the hologram you see you know different images and it does different things.
So, yeah, you can uh do that, and they're called multiple channel holograms.
And uh the public always wants to see something happen with a hologram, and that's that's the way to do it, you know, put multiple channel holograms out there.
Um if if someone walks into a shop and they just see a hologram and it doesn't do anything, they're always asking, well, what's this hologram supposed to do?
It doesn't do anything.
Well, some holograms don't do anything, they're just holograms.
You know, look at them and enjoy it just for what it is.
Uh second question.
This is coming from RW, and in the last name, I won't say the last name, so we'll just say it's from RW.
Is it possible to make or design holographic images by computer?
Yes, it is.
Um we're we're using a computer to do uh holograms of the Titanic, and what we're doing is we have the archival film footage uh from the uh Titanic expedition expeditions, excuse me, from uh uh Bob Ballard and uh Dr.
Ballard.
I've I've been working with the Jason project uh for a couple years now, and Dr.
Ballard's involved with that project, and I've got some of the expedition footage from the Titanic, and what we're doing is uh you have to it has to meet certain criteria in order to make it a good hologram.
The camera has to be moving horizontally as it's passing the object, and then you can take individual frames and then uh synthesize them into a holographic stereogram uh frame by frame.
So that's one way of using a computer.
Now, can you make a hologram directly from computer computer information?
Yes, you can.
If you have a 3D design program, you can design an object and take a frame and so many degrees of rotation and send that to a frame printer and then uh uh rotate it a few more degrees and send that to another uh uh uh frame printer where it comes out on film and you can use that film frame by frame to do the same thing.
And I believe I I've read I I don't know how popular this is or how often this occurs, but I I believe that computers can actually write holographic information itself and create a hologram uh specifically from the data itself rather than the image.
And then it goes to a holographic printer that uh exposes the film or the plate uh almost uh pixel by pixel, and it's an incredibly long process to do that.
Um I'm trying to think of a third way.
I had it right in the back of my head and I'm losing it here.
Hold on.
Well, I put it on pause to try and think of this other way, and that click, it's gone.
I guess similarity's starting to set in.
But anyway, that should give you a couple examples of computer holograms, computer holography.
Okay, hello, I'm David.
Won't say the last name.
Oh, I was at your workshop, okay.
I'm one of my workshop participants, and I have two questions about lasers and holograms.
The first one is how a laser's made.
Second one is how are holograms made.
Well, geez, I'll tell you what, David, I mean uh uh we did cover this in the workshop, but maybe you just want me to answer the question on the air.
I understand.
Uh lasers are made.
Well, there's a lot of different lasers, and it would take a long time to go through all the different types of lasers that there are.
It's a long question uh long answer to a short question uh to go into that.
Uh the most popular lasers, I'll tell you this, uh, are uh helium neon lasers used for holography.
Most of your amateur and hobbyist philographers are using helium neon lasers.
They're very inexpensive, they have a long life, uh, 20,000 hours plus.
And um they're basically a glass tube that is uh about the size of a drinking straw, the actual uh place where the lasing action takes place, and that glass tube is filled with the mixtures of the gases, helium and neon.
It's the same helium that you find in the helium birthday balloons, it's the same neon that you find in the neon pizza signs when you go out at night to pick up a pizza.
And just like a pizza sign, when you apply power to that tube, that tube lights up just like the pizza sign does.
Now, even though most of the light's escaping through the sides of the tube, we do have mirrors that are placed on the ends of the tube, and the light begins to reflect back and forth between the two mirrors.
Uh one of the mirrors is uh partially reflective, which means when the light is being reflected back and forth between those two mirrors, this specific mirror allows a certain amount of the light to come through, a certain percentage, and that comes through as the laser beam.
Uh, how are holograms made?
Well, holograms are made using the laser.
There are certain properties of laser light that we need in order to make a hologram.
The light needs to be monochromatic, which means it's one color and one color only at a given time.
And the light source also has to be coherent, which means all of the waves that are traveling out of that laser are in step with one another in what I like to term wave train.
And it are it's these properties of the laser itself and the laser light specifically that allow us to make the holograms.
The holograms are made in usually holographic labs, either professional laboratories or amateur studios that you find in some people's basements and even out in garages.
There's a holographic table that's usually used, and this holographic table is used to dampen vibrations coming up from the floor.
It needs to be a very stiff table so that you don't get a lot of flex, and that laser beam travels around the table.
For a simple hologram, you just need one beam with the object placed behind the plate and spread that laser beam out and cover it with light.
More complex holograms, you take that laser beam and break it up into a bunch of different beams using a beam splitter.
Send it around the table.
You may have one, two, three, or more object beams illuminating your object, and one beam, which is specifically used to illuminate the holographic plate or film, which is called the reference beam.
It doesn't have to be a very complex process.
It can be very simple, and you don't necessarily have to have a large holographic table.
I've made holograms on top of tabletops just using a few simple items in order to make the hologram itself.
So David, I hope that answers your question.
Thank you very much for sending it in, and I hope you enjoyed the workshop.
Here we have another quote another question that was sent in from email.
This is from Farah.
I am doing a report for school concerning holograms.
My problem is that I can't find any good information regarding the optics involved with holography.
Please send me any information you can answer it on your holo talk show.
I think you should go to the link page, number one, and uh try and find uh one of the links.
Yeah, just go down the page and read the descriptions and find if uh see if you can find a site that deals a little bit more with holography and the optics.
I know there has to be something out there on the web that will give you some information on the optics.
But like I answered with David's question, we do not need to have a very complex optical system in order to do holograms.
Uh to do a hologram, the least amount of optics that you would need would just be one lens, which would take that laser beam and spread it out and give it enough area to cover the holographic plate with the object behind it, and that would be a single beam reflection hologram that you can view with light light.
Uh there are other pieces of optical equipment that you can add to your system for more complex setups, uh things such as collimating mirrors, which takes the diverging wave front of that expanding laser light and puts it into a parallel beam.
Also, there are uh spatial filters, which the light can go through.
It goes through an objective lens which focuses it down to a very small point.
And at that point in space, there is a pinhole, which is usually 10, twenty five microns in diameter.
It's very tiny, and we pass that laser light right at that focal point through the pinhole in the spatial filter.
That cleans up the profile of the beam.
Anyone who's done amateur holography knows that a lot of times when you take a beam and you send it through a lens and you show that expanded beam on a white card, you'll notice that it's uh it's not it's pretty crappy looking sometimes if you're just using a lens.
What a spatial filter does is it cleans that profile.
It's actually a beautiful spread light, uh spread beam of laser light that uh focuses, uh not focuses, but uh shows up on the white card, and it uh really improves the overall quality of the holograms immensely when you use a spatial filter.
But it's not necessary to do that.
So there are questions for the week.
I don't think we have any more.
Thank you very much for sending the questions in.
If you have any more questions, please send them in.
We try to get the questions in on the uh odd weeks.
Uh every other week we have a guest, and every other week beside that we have the odd week, which we do different things, and a lot of times those things are answering questions.
So not to make this show run on and on and on.
So what I'm going to say is thank you very much for tuning in.
Remember, our guest next week is Steve Crovince from Blue Ridge Holographics.
And if everything goes as planned, that show will go up at August August, geez, April 12th, which is Sunday night.
So you want to tune in and see if uh that show's up.
If it's not up, I'll have a message to let you know when to expect that show to be up.
So thank you for tuning in to HoloTalk.
This is Frankie Fratis.
Take care and see you next week.